[Inaudible].
It's here now, though, from our second speaker for the motion for Hina yummy,
she's an international environmental lawyer and activist with extinction
rebellion.
She was a negotiator on the Paris agreement with the small Island States in
April last year, she was arrested after gluing herself to Shell's headquarters.
And she's a co-author of, this is not a drill and extinction rebellion handbook.
[Inaudible].
Well, thank you very much.
There's a lot in what Adair Turner has said that I agree with.
And we must accept that the solutions to
preventing climate chaos,
preventing climate carnage actually exist. They exist today.
Most of the technologies that we need to use to bring emissions under
control exists today.
I think what capitalism doesn't do is deal with the social injustices
that are already happening with the global warming that we've committed to,
and that will continue to rise.
Should we also miss the 1.5 degree target and go
overshooting beyond that?
At the moment we have a kind of capitalism that does not
look after any of us. It doesn't look after the people in the UK.
It doesn't look after the people overseas. It doesn't look after the planet.
It does not look after nature.
So I feel that maybe to add to George's definition of
capitalism,
a simple way is maybe to see capitalism as a pyramid of
extraction. That's what capitalism is.
It's a pyramid where people and nature are at the bottom and
profits and wealth and power accumulate towards the top.
They've accumulated in such obscene quantities that they threaten the very
nature of our Democrat democracies.
They used to be a tenuous kind of link between capitalism and
democracy, but actually that link isn't really true. And if anything,
that link is going in the reverse direction.
So why did I choose to speak for this motion?
Why did I choose to join the rebels back in April?
I've got two books here and it's not because I want you to buy them and sell
them and buy this one by the way, because all the profits go.
I want you to climate change and carbon markets book that I wrote
and came out in 2005,
when he spent the first decade of my life as a climate change, lawyer,
negotiating the UNF to see the climate convention.
And then the Kyoto protocol and Kyoto protocol gave rise to carbon markets,
which were also developed in the European union.
So I've got quite a lot of history of being
into the very of regulations. The very kinds of incentives,
the very kinds of market mechanisms that Adair has said can constrain
capitalism can constrain and control pollution. And 20,
30 years later, I have to say, those mechanisms do not work.
They don't work.
All of the experts now agree that using emissions trading for a
structural problem like climate change does not work.
We're not talking about an end of pipe. What we call, you know, fix it,
solution a technology that we can just use and ask
power, power stations, for example, to bolt on in the way they did with sulfur.
We're asking for an entire rejigging of the global economy
of every country's energy system of every countries,
agricultural system of every country's transport system of every
citizens, aspirational desires.
That is what we call a systemic challenge.
That is the carbon economy that we need to change.
And we cannot regulate it simply by looking at all the technologies that are
available and saying somehow magically the system will adopt them.
I think the, the, my disillusion slightly, you know,
intellectual as it was with the kinds of mechanisms that we were
being, uh, urged to, to, to,
to put forward as solutions really came to a head as it became more
and more clear that the influence, the power,
the preponderance political power of the biggest corporations in the world,
all of which trade in, in carbon intensive products,
oil, gas, coal, you name it. Those are the biggest ones.
Those companies, whether they're state owned or privately owned,
those were lobbying and, uh,
controlling the sort of narrative and greenwashing and actually
heavily influencing the way in which elections take place.
You see that very clearly behind the scenes. If you're a day-to-day lawyer,
as I have been in the, in the climate regime,
you see regulations being vetoed, water down,
you see permits that were meant to be constrained given out for free, uh,
being given out in access,
which means that none of these mechanisms really worked. Um, my final
trigger for gluing myself to shell was really a report that
came out,
which said that since the signing of the Paris agreement in 2015,
$1 billion had been spent by the top five oil
companies in the world on lobbying and marketing and greenwashing.
That was for me,
a really important sense of outrage that I felt, I don't know,
he can see this here, but this is like a,
I don't know if he could see this tiny sliver, you know,
someone served you that as a cake slice, it wouldn't be a slice.
It would be a sliver that little tiny grip or in sliver is the slice
of funding by the oil majors that goes into low carbon
and green sources of energy. All of the rest.
This is a 2019 figures goes into still digging
out, exploring and producing yet more. Fossil fuels.
The scale of this destruction is immense
Saudi Arabia, Saudi Aramco, which is the largest,
most profitable company in the entire world produces
profits of around $3,000 per
second, around 300 million per day.
So trying to control and regulate companies as large
as that, essentially sleep is a geopolitical challenge.
It is not a technological challenge.
We have to find a different system for constraining,
these sorts of dynamics. And I feel that's what we haven't really understood.
I want very much to say that there is a level playing field and somehow the new
technologies that are there has talked about, which are there most of them,
by the way, will they won't,
they won't because the largest share of government handout,
what we call fossil fuel subsidies. You just call them for what they are.
Government handouts are being paid to fossil fuel companies still
because they have political power and control.
The scale of those subsidies is mind boggling.
So there's two ways of counting these subsidies. If you include the,
the cost of actual damage,
they come to like $5 trillion.
That's an obscene. The huge amount means that these companies are being
supported by governments and they have taken control
of the economy in ways that does not lend itself to a sort of
reformist mindset.
That's why I think the young people and people who
are really active in politics are coming up with much
more radical solutions.
So I don't want to leave you with a lack of hope and lack of alternatives.
I think big business, especially big business and finance Ks,
the heart of the global finance industry are need to
be absolutely controlled with regulation.
We need to say stop funding and financing these activities.
We need to say to our governments very clearly stop using taxpayers money
to support and subsidize these same industries.
We need to say to the CEOs of these companies and the finance
industry, you are failing humanity.
We have to make very clear that what they're leaving us with is the challenge,
especially to younger people of reversing this cup cataclysmic
breakdown, they're leaving the burden of coping emotionally,
physically, mentally,
and rebuilding institutions of trust because young people and people
all over this country, especially those who have not gained from globalization,
not gained from capitalism,
no longer trust governments and no longer believe that we can
bring prosperity in the way that they have been led to expect.
I think it's very important to accept that the public actually have a visceral
understanding of the failings of capitalism and have already rejected it.
That's what's happening it up and down the world.
Whether you look at the Chilean miners who have
rejected, and the people in Chile who turned out in their millions,
there's Malaysians, you know,
there's a student strikers everywhere you look,
there is an outcry and a desire and an appetite for huge amounts of change.
I think what would really help is a structural 10 year
plan. You can call it the green new deal, the nature, new deal,
something like the Marshall plan that was done after the second world war
to bring together, to bring societies together,
to look globally and to make sure that we put in place a system,
which is a kin to the natural national health service.
And I would call it the natural health services,
what we now need for the whole planet.
[Inaudible].